dulces
acaso una sociedad necesita artistas
es realmente necesario que la
colectividad del sueño y a la luz de un
pensamiento pragmático y utilidad
práctica tendría
como director de orquesta y tarea que
involucra una gran cantidad de gestión y
comunicación con especialistas de muy
diversas áreas me he visto en la
necesidad de los últimos años
especialmente de ir diseñando respuestas
a cuestiones como estas y es que
imaginación y fantasía no son los mismos
o facultades distintas mientras la
imaginación rescata la representación
mental de algo que conocemos en el mundo
real y pragmático la fantasía tiene el
potencial infinito de crear nuevas
representaciones nunca antes conocidas
de manera previa mitologías imágenes
fantásticas o fantasmagóricas medusas
quimeras antiguas y modernas
la impresión de un amanecer o de la
naturaleza campirana nuevas
combinaciones de colores trazos formas
de texturas de materiales o la
combinación de todo lo anterior
elementos reales elementos con elementos
irreales
la imaginación apela a la memoria a la
memoria de un recuerdo
es la fantasía que junto con la técnica
y el trabajo incansable de un creador
hacen hacer la obra artística
quizás podemos pensar en la cultura
simplemente como todo aquello que no es
producido por la naturaleza y que sin
embargo es connatural al hombre el
hombre que piensa que idealiza que cree
y que crea las distintas bellas artes
y las distintas mitologías
y las tradiciones folklóricas y las
festividades son todas ellas distintas
formas de cultura en cuyo ingrediente
básico encuentran la fantasía
ya quizás esa capacidad de crear mundos
paralelos el distintivo entre el ser
humano y el mundo animal ya quizás un
distintivo incluso entre varios seres
humanos
el arte como profesión tendría un
impacto en la sociedad contemporánea es
que puede coadyuvar a la investigación
científica o como lo ha hecho desde
tiempos inmemoriales generar proximidad
entre culturas lejanas exaltar valores
patrióticos nacionales religiosos
generar cohesión de grupos
y construir el sentimiento de lo
ceremonial o lo trascendental
en la edad media
mediante el estudio del quadrivium estas
cuatro áreas del conocimiento llamadas
artes liberales existía el estudio de la
música de una manera regular
el 4 y 1 se centraba en el estudio del
número el número per se
siendo la aritmética el número en el
tiempo la música
el número en el espacio la geometría y
el número en el tiempo en el espacio la
astronomía es apenas hace cinco siglos
cinco siglos aproximadamente más o menos
con la el nacimiento del pensamiento
científico moderno de la educación
musical fue considerándose cada vez más
optativa y paradójicamente hoy por hoy
es la ciencia y la técnica las que nos
plantean un interesante retorno o
digamos balance porque porque toda esta
evidencia nueva que ha arrojado sobre la
potenciación cognitiva que las artes
desarrollan en el ser humano es cada vez
más vasta hoy a la luz de la ciencia
sabemos por ejemplo que la música sea
quizás la actividad que más regiones del
cerebro active en una tarea simultánea
es así como por ejemplo un ritmo regular
irregular continuo o interrupto se
percibe en la corteza prefrontal que
crea las expectativas mientras la
corteza motora se ocupa del movimiento
marca
con el pie bailar tocar un instrumento
la corteza sensorial retroalimenta
táctil mente al tocar un instrumento o
bailar
la corteza auditiva lleva a cabo las
primeras etapas de la escucha de las
señales sonoras la corteza visual se
ocupa de la lectura de la música o capta
los movimientos del músico incluyo
inclusive los de uno mismo el cerebelo
todo lo motor también se ocupa de
reacciones emocionales a la música dando
como resultado esta bella total
en un corte medio sagital del cerebro
seguimos observando que el cuerpo
calloso este puente entre los dos
hemisferios cerebrales es ricamente
activado por la música gana dando una
experiencia completa del cerebro el
núcleo accumbens y la amígdala cerebral
se ocupan de relés de reacciones
emocionales a la música el ico el
hipocampo de la memoria para la música y
otras experiencias y de nuevo el
cerebelo dando como total prácticamente
todo el cerebro humano en un estudio de
2010 se comparó a músicos y no músicos
en cerebros y se observó que
efectivamente el cuerpo calloso que
conecta ambos hemisferios creció hacia
la parte anterior engrosándose y
desplaza
y es que a mayor gusto por la música
mayor actividad cerebral en esta
imagen producida por la resonancia
magnética se muestra un sujeto que
escucha música que no le gusta entonces
las señales localizadas en sólo un punto
del cerebro muy similar al ruido que no
tiene significado en asociaciones pero
en esta otra la música es de su agrado
activa más regiones y se maximiza hasta
llegar a ésta cuando escucha su música a
favor
o sea esta bella metáfora visual una
sugerencia del cerebro como una caja de
resonancia de la cual emanan emociones
vivencias y recuerdos muy particulares
para cada individuo
y es que el sonido es un fenómeno físico
la música es un fenómeno metafísico el
sonido no significa nada en sí mismo a
diferencia de la palabra es imposible
acudir a un diccionario a una
enciclopedia a buscarla consultar la
acepción convencional de una combinación
de ritmos timbres matices y dinámicas
por lo tanto la música con este grado de
abstracción no retrata una realidad
tangible como las artes plásticas no usa
los colores y sus formas y se constituye
como un lenguaje mediante meramente
universal un medio universal que no ha
faltado en ninguna civilización desde el
origen desde la especie
en cada uno de los 11 países en los que
he tenido oportunidad de dirigir porque
estás he comprobado una y otra vez el
inmenso poder de encantamiento que las
grandes obras maestras generan ante
cualquier tipo de audiencia no
importando sus diferencias culturales
raciales étnicas de edad
etcétera aquí mismo en culiacán el
frente de la orquesta sinfónica sinaloa
de las artes con la cual colaboró como
director artístico me he vuelto testigo
concierto tras concierto del enorme
poder capaz catalizador de una buena
ejecución en vivo puede producir en una
sociedad en una comunidad y más aún
perdurar por días y días en esta misma
audiencia cada uno de nosotros al
escuchar el mismo ejemplo musical las
notas más famosas de la música quizás el
principio de la quinta sinfonía de
beethoven evocar y amos a sus que
haríamos de la manera más y perú
[Música]
bueno
y
[Música]
bien
e
[Música]
cómo
las grandes obras maestras son pequeños
mundos perfectos fantásticos que habitan
junto con nosotros de manera paralela
encapsuladas delimitadas por la técnica
artística y la fantasía que le dio
origen un gen como ejemplos virtuosos en
la sociedad aquel que asiste a un
concierto un gran evento cultural se
convierte en testigo de modelos
producidos y manufacturados por mentes
soñadores el que asiste es iluminado de
alguna manera aquel que asiste
regularmente y le inspira
un país que tiene artistas es un país
que sabes que sabe pensar en lógicas
mayores más allá de la lógica básica 123
abc quizás la lógica z4 asterisco m o en
cualquier orden y sin embargo llegar a
la solución o a muchas más un país
desarrollado se siente a sus
instituciones artísticas promoviendo
además su multiplicación nunca habrá
demasiadas
mi propuesta es buscar conciertos
eventos culturales aquellos donde la
programación especialmente incluya obras
desconocidas
indaga asiste
vuélvete testigo de todo esto busca esta
experiencia creativa que nos obliga a
ser mejores en cualquiera de los rubros
profesionales a los cuales nos
dediquemos inunda tu mente de
pensamiento artístico nunca he conocido
a nadie que sumergiéndose en esta
travesía haya regresado a solicitar la
devolución de su tiempo
ciertamente así como un cuerpo raquítico
hace morir a el alma un alma sin
alimento termina por hacer morir
muchas gracias